Shayne est un jeune pilote de course irlandais
qui est évidemment venu aux États-Unis
à un très jeune âge et il arrive
avec ce talent et essaie vraiment de le
faire sur le circuit aux États-
Unis, l'
une des grandes choses à propos de Shane est
qu'il transmet  ténacité mais en même
temps il a un vrai sens de l'humour
tu vas inventer le moyen de sortir de celui-
ci
Jane n'a pas peur de se battre et de s'y
mettre avec quelqu'un et il
s'inscrira pour ce qu'il pense qu'il veut  de se
lever des
restes c'est super pour moi c'est une
expérience incroyable de pouvoir venir
sur le plateau d'un film comme celui-ci tous les jours
et je me sens très honoré de faire partie d'un